[Musique]
ces formes insolites ces immenses
bâtiments d'acier de verre
c'est le nouveau montparnasse tout s'y
construit à une nouvelle échelle tout
devient projection sur l'avenir
[Musique]
on y voit toujours des artistes mais il
est bien loin le vieux montparnasse des
moulins des guinguettes des balles
chantelle loin celui des années folles
cher aux écrivains et aux artistes
celui qui aimait apollinaire mode il ya
ni le douanier rousseau et picasso max
jacob
celui où trônent l'oeuvre de rodin ici
un nouveau quartier ultra moderne est en
train de naître dans une ville en voie
d'évolution
c'est la plus vaste opération de
rénovation jamais entreprise dans paris
il s'agit d'une expérience unique en
pleine capitale un vaste ensemble
commercial résidentiel avec des services
publics dans ce nouveau quartier
d'affaires montparnasse d'aujourd'hui
préfigure demain landes mis depuis près
de trois ans des milliers de parisiens
apprennent à vivre dans ce pari des
temps modernes
la tour de maine montparnasse de
conception audacieuse qui sera comme on
l'a dit le clocher de l'ensemble a été
l'objet d'une bataille assez âpre qui a
opposé souvent partisans et détracteurs
monsieur françois hébert président
directeur général de la ces mam c'est
tour a été pensé et repensé par les
architectes au lait uht énormément de
projets il ya eu d'abord entendre dans
la première période j'ai eu peu de 56
1958 et eu au moins 36 est bon avant
projet différent là était rondelle et et
rectangulaire et maintenant on dit elle
maintenant elle est ovale
elle est ovale et là une forme en
amendes cette forme en allemande a été
voulu par nos architectes en 1965 pour
justement éviter l'effet de mur qu'on
aurait pu craindre de la part d'une part
des deux tours trop vertical est trop
répandue
ou dernièrement puisque c'est tout au
courant du premier trimestre 1967
cette tour est encore présenté à la
commission des sites et au conseil
général des bâtiments de france
et grâce à cette occasion on a réduit sa
longueur
je parlais tout à l'heure de 75 m elle
n'a plus maintenant qu'une soixantaine
de mètres
par contre sa hauteur et a été porté à
200 mètres devant le plan de la nouvelle
gare montparnasse monsieur stains qui
est directeur de la région ouest de la
sncf
la nouvelle gare à à 22 voix de quelques
400 mètres alors que l'ancien on n'avait
que quatorze si je ne me trompe de 200 à
300 m sur le deuxième point celui des
aménagements intérieurs
la nouvelle garde comportera au tournant
hall que vous voyez là de quelques sons
m sur 3 m des guichets de billets un
bureau de renseignements moderne où on
attendra à sa place d'être appelé par
numéro d'ordre bientôt des distributeurs
de billets automatiques rendant la
monnaie
bientôt également le la location
électronique des places et pour les
voyageurs autour de soul toujours des
salles d'attentes moderne un accueil de
l'enfance un accueil de la jeune fille
le foyer social breton a du goût de
tourisme une banque et une opération de
change connexes et enfin un restaurant
de quelques 250 places on a dit de cette
gare qu'elle serait très moderne
révolutionnaire est votre sentiment nous
avons essayé de faire moderne mais sans
risquer d'être taxé bientôt d'être de
grand papa et je pense que la meilleure
le milieu sera que les voyageurs
eux-mêmes en juge et un juge dès l'année
prochaine car nos mettrons en service la
gare entre le mois de février est le
mois de juin 1969
ici même au dessus même de la voie
ferrée de la gare maine-montparnasse il
y aura un jour un jardin suspendu
ainsi michel caldaguès qui est président
du conseil de paris et qui est aussi
membre du conseil d'administration de la
société qui s'occupe de l'opération
maine montparnasse est à l'origine de
cette idée de jardins suspendus
l'hymne est apparu très rapidement il y
avait là une occasion unique de réaliser
dans paris pour la première fois depuis
des dizaines d'années un espace vert de
grande dimension en effet la couverture
des vraies voix que nous avons
actuellement sous les yeux soit au total
4 hectares et demi
ouverture par une dalle de béton coûte
environ 1000 francs le mètre carré alors
qu'il est bien évident qu'on ne peut pas
libérer de terrain nulle part à paris
pour un prix équivalent et que compte
tenu des expropriations
sans compter les demies démolition
d'immeubles et le relogement de leurs
occupants ga n'importe où la libération
du seul coûte beaucoup plus cher passé
en quelque sorte le parc monceau d'harry
gauche
j'avais suspendu de 4 hectares et demi
et qui sera conçue selon toutes les
conceptions des termes de choix ce sera
exactement un jardin public comme ceux
qui existent déjà à paris actuellement
je parlais à l'instant du parc monceau
dans un jardin public avec des jeunes
enfants des bassins les accès en 2d
facile oui les actions seront faciles on
pourra accéder à partir d'ici à partir
du pont des saints martyrs et vian aussi
une communication avec le secteur 2 de
maine montparnasse et à travers lui
avec le nouveau quartier des lots van
damme qui doit être rénové dont la
rénovation doit commencer prochainement
par conséquent les habitants du quartier
du 14ème arrondissement en cours on y
accéder très facilement et de façon
générale ceux de tous les quartiers
environnants
monsieur bruce m
un député de paris ancien vice président
du conseil municipal vous avez été
monsieur favorable à ce projet de m
montparnasse et vous avez vous voulu
aussi habité ici je souhaitais est
habité par ce que précisément je voulais
goûter aux charmes du pari de l'an 2000
pensez vous que le quartier va être
marquée par la présence de cette
construction 1,7
il y aura toujours à montparnasse
l'écoquartier représenté par cet
ensemble et puis les bas quartiers mais
qui ne seront pas des quartiers étaient
laissés se sont tous plus tôt c'est à
l'ombre de ce vaste ensemble que les
plaies et les patrons et les
chansonniers continueront de se réunir
en fait montparnasse deviennent grands
centres d'affaires de la rive gauche sur
cinq bâtiments de vous l'avez vue sont
des appartements locatifs 79 % des
locataires sont des cadres des
fonctionnaires
mais l'opération rénovation continue les
îlots plaisance et van damme vont
disparaître sur les anciens ateliers
vétustes on édifiera 10 800 logements
dont les deux tiers seront des hlm
fait nouveau les expropriés seront
relogés dans le quartier même paris
change de visage dans notre époque en
accélération il faut voir plus grand
plus large
[Musique]